now I can try again I need to know why
you don't like it the food is really
important we really decided to do it as
a metaphor for what going on in each
episode and also what the main
characters are feeling and especially
shot I mean I literally can't taste okay
now you're being rude and yep guests
food has to feed emotionally into the
characters and automatically into the
episode he advises for some of the best
restaurants in the city
I feed butter and cream to fair people
as shown is the kind of chef that likes
to challenge you
so whatever he finds he wants to cook
strawberry lobster Julian the food's a
huge part and we're taking what Anthony
bas Khalaf has written and making sure
that it's usable so it's nice it's a lot
of life imitating art and a lot of very
giving people who are willing to learn
and willing to impart their knowledge
and what they've learned Marc Vetri is
one of the great chefs in the world so
we asked him would he want to be the
consultant on the show and we're so
lucky to have Herrmann chef drew here to
be on set every day setting everything
up you know designing and talking us
through everything
also Toby who plays Shawn loves the
cookies all in there in the kitchen and
on the sets which is a real kitchen and
they're cooking stuff and so it makes it
feel real in every way cause it is real
you know done I mean she likes the idea
of spicy food but in reality it doesn't
agree with her so as long as she
believes it's there she swear she can
taste it really when you get into food
and you talked to a lot of chefs and
you're dealing with that they see it as
life-giving that's how it's been
threaded through the show that the food
yes is extravagant and over-the-top and
kind of a little overbearing but in the
end really is life game trout is
delicious I love precision of food and I
do find the great chefs super inspiring
to me I'm inspired by how they're driven
the precision of it the discipline
involved in the craft I try to bring
that here
[Music]
you
you